in thirty seconds
you are starting to be interested in geos
here are three digital resources to follow
the first one is on instagram
it is called the geopolitical magazine
and every day
you can find slides
of geopolitical news
which is detailed
then it's on youtube
there is the unstoppable chain
the bottom of the cards
the bottom of the cards will rule out
the videos last about
always less than fifteen minutes
and it makes it explicit
of the major current issues in geos
and the whole is illustrated
with specialists and geo maps
the last one is a piece of france culture
international issues
it is presented by julie gacon
it allows to stay
on the lookout for international news
and here it is